[Music]
hey what's up this is john with the dr
john dolone show with a special
christmas edition i hope you are doing
well i just got this picture of you
either you've already opened christmas
presents and your dad's already driving
you crazy
or your husband keeps making that stupid
face in his sweatpants that are too
tight
your kids didn't like what they got
christmas doesn't look like you thought
it was going to or you had to go to work
today
whatever it is we weren't going to do a
show then it was like no
let's just reach out and do something
light and do something fun
and so here's what we're going to do
today on the dr john dolone's show
and by the way it's so annoying to talk
about yourself in the third person so
we're going to do this on this little
podcast how about that
is i found out the other day that kelly
daniel
who is the call screener who takes the
calls goes through these emails
she crafts the show and james childs who
runs the board
he edits the shows he makes everything
happen he is the producer of the show
she's the associate producer of the show
and then zach bennett back there on the
tubes he makes sure all the cameras work
and everything's going
so they are we are in the studio
together all the time
they've been keeping secret titles
to the shows since we started we just
finished the 50th episode
and they've been creating an air table
so i've invited them to be on the show
today
james kelly good to see y'all merry
christmas christmas
and also with you merry christmas and so
you've been keeping a secret uh
excel sheet like a secret spreadsheet of
alternate show titles even before we
started the show when you started
co-hosting the show with dave ramsey
there were certain phrases you would
start to say
that you would repeat fairly often and i
was like these are too good
to not document so so
this is them making fun of me let's go
ahead
we only make fun because we love oh if
we don't make fun of you
we don't care and that's actually what i
believe too
so y'all want to read these you want me
to read these
i'm just seeing these for the first time
so i'll go through them
okay yeah so instead of the dr john
deloney show here's some alternative
titles go to breakfast with dr john
deloney
that's pretty self-explanatory i do say
that a lot that's right amygdala
with dr john deloney i don't even know
what that means but
do i say that either neither does anyone
else but you say it a lot
god almighty with dr john deloney i
didn't say that too much
oh this is annoying what a gift with dr
john delaney
i've got to quit saying that
whack-a-doodle-doo
with dr john deloney that'd be awesome
do you use that one
that sucks with dr jonciloni that could
also
be the title of some of our marriages
but we'll go to the next one
um it's just a fire alarm with dr john
yeah i do say that a lot
what is up every show
every show so i listen my friend todd
whitaker in texas
he's the one who used to always say what
is up and somehow i just became part of
my vernacular
and now it can be an alternate show
title this is my personal
favorite rocket diarrhea with dr john
doloni
you know every piece of my being
that you don't like diarrhea humor no i
do not like bathroom humor
james shaw you're someone with two
doctorate degrees you do an awful lot of
bathrooms oh
so much about your coffee mug i do have
a
coffee mug it's right over there so my
sister bought it for me john and i are
in a meeting one day he walks in
and sets his coffee mug down that says
be nice to me
i have diarrhea and the first thing i
said is that we'll never
ever be on camera so far my sister
is the is the funniest person i know
she's as hilarious she's awesome and she
got me that coffee mug and i didn't
think about it it was just perfect and
i just brought it to work and of course
kelly saw it
so i don't think that diarrhea humor is
contingent on how many degrees you have
that's just me but whatever
all right the next one is gangster ninja
with dr john deloney
do i say that a lot you say when you're
talking about like how awesome someone
is like your wife or your grandma or
something choose a gangster yeah the
word awesome
my buddy nate tells me that awesome is
used by like
young youth ministers and people who
hang out with high school kids
like yeah guys that's awesome and
occasionally i'll say it and right as it
comes out i just feel like an idiot
and so somehow it became gangster ninjas
i don't even know where that came from
yeah that definitely doesn't sound as
immature as awesome
people of the internets with dr john
dolone
again i don't i can't i talk to you i
can't see you i don't know so you're
just
you're out there people of the internets
humor grace and grit i don't say that
that's an inside joke because somebody
wrote that as your copy early on and you
said i hate that
so i just put that in there to fight you
okay good job
real talk with do i say we're gonna do
real talk that was another thing
that was another thing they were doing
those original like teasers
before they you met me yeah some quack
on the radio
yeah i used to say that especially in
the beginning days i was
super self-conscious you don't think
you're a quack anymore you got a little
big head now no i just say it a little
more explicitly and you'll
beep it out or edit it out i live in the
woods with dr john delon that is true
i say that a lot low level hum
sounds like a meditation joke james not
appreciate it
not by your hand but in your lap i love
that one
yeah no do i say that too much no you
say it appropriately
all right this is it guys this is the
name of the show
box of farts with dr johnson here we go
again
would you not when you're scrolling down
a podcast would you not stop
on box of farts and think i should
probably listen to this one
our ratings would definitely go no our
ratings would go through the roof
our listen time would not but our click
on rate would be huge
you can drink and drive did i say that
you said that in a show one time
out of order and you corrected yourself
but we're not gonna let you forget that
all right you can drink and drive with
dr john delony
this one who hurt you
who hurt you with dr john delaney wasn't
that like a reddit thing tell that so
the running joke is that
uh when you co-host the dave ramsey show
you know dave will say
you know somebody will call in and say
hey um i'm upside down in my truck what
do i do and he's like how much money do
you make
and that your go-to question for
everything is you know they could be
calling about a money question you're
like
who hurt you when you were young
[Laughter]
this is your default that's part of our
trifecta
the trifecta yeah how in the world are
you with dr john delaney i do ask that a
lot
um waiting on john with dr john delany
what does that mean
yeah uh you've gotten better about it
but early on in the recording days we
would often be waiting on you
to start recording i think i think
that's no secret you were you were sent
to me as from god as a lesson in
patience
just a little patience yeah learned
behavior with dr john deloney do i say
that a lot
yeah not a whole lot to learn and then
the last one
all of it with dr that's a good title
yeah all of it i like that why don't we
call to show that
it's better than the doctor john dolonia
show me we do deal with all
of it so there's one more that i
couldn't i don't know how to type it but
it'd be a good one
at the end of almost every show you do
this thing where you go
you know what i'm talking about yes i
can't i didn't know how to type it but
that
yeah that could be one too so zach
you're the silent
engineer back there you don't have any i
don't have a microphone
oh he doesn't have attributed to a lot
of these too all right we all came up
with them
all right well so those are alternative
show titles anything else y'all want to
add
we just passed 50 show mark i know can
you believe it
no i can't i mean really who'd have
thought that we're closing
those i mean the numbers have just
gotten cartoonish it's just bananas when
we signed up for this we thought it
would be kind of a pilot one or two
episodes thing and then fall flat
yeah we really didn't think we were we
already had jobs yeah
and by the way y'all are listening these
aren't just like uh
schmoes these guys are the producer
and senior associate producer of like
one of the most
with the number three show in in the
country
right it's not like they are chumps
they're running things
zach runs the youtube channel for the
dave ramsey show
and they were like man diloni needs so
much help we're gonna have to
we're gonna have to pull people who
actually know we thought well we'll do
this and then we'll clearly it won't
work so we'll get to go back to our
regular jobs
and that's a lot so i would like to say
publicly we've crossed the the 50
episode mark it's going better than i
think any of us could have ever imagined
so thank you kelly
for crafting these shows and for saying
no john that's a stupid idea
that's terrible we're not doing that
james for saying
nothing but then you tell blake on me
and then blake calls and says john we
are not going to do that thing actually
you don't do that you tell me
the way things work and for actually
knowing how all this works and zack
the silent wonder the ninja
the gangster ninja thumbs up behind the
videos
yeah what i get from zach often is this
and so to you zack thumbs up to you
brother
and so here's to another i don't know a
couple thousand shows and to all of
y'all listening
i want to wish you a merry christmas
happy holidays you gotta say something
no i was just gonna say don't forget
about the lyrics i forgot that my mic
was on
oh so yeah he's talking to you he's
always talking to me but he
this is a show um in a song i'm in a
cold read it's a christmas song
happy holidays merry christmas happy
hanukkah
everyone is listening to this i wish you
great blessings this season
thank you for whatever it is you're
doing right now lean into it
take a deep breath exhale go back out
and be with your family
leave if you have to go back to work
thank you so much for joining us and
hope you'll stay with us as the show
continues to grow
so as we wrap up today's show here is
the greatest christmas song
of all time by wham
it's called what
last christmas last christmas by william
george michael and company
you gotta have faith the faith of faith
and the song goes like this
ah aha oh last christmas i gave you my
heart but the very next day you gave it
away
this year to save me from tears i'll
give it to someone special
last christmas i gave you my heart but
the very next day you gave it away
you gave it away this year to save me
from tears i'll give it to someone
special
special once bitten and twice shy i keep
my distance
but you still catch my eye tell me baby
do you recognize me
well it's been a year it doesn't
surprise me merry christmas
i wrapped it up and sent it with a note
saying i love you i meant it
now i know what a fool i've been but if
you kissed me now
i know you'd fool me again a crowded
room
friends with tired eyes i'm hiding from
you and your soul of ice
my god i thought you were someone to
rely on me i guess i was just a shoulder
to cry on
a face of a lover with a fire in his
heart
a man under cover but you tore me apart
now i found a real love you'll never
fool me again
last christmas i gave you my heart but
the very next day you gave it away
you gave it away this year to save me
from tears i'll give it to someone
special
special last christmas i gave you my
heart i gave you my heart
but the very next day you gave it away
that is not the greatest song of all
time even close
we could have gone with mariah carey but
we went with wham this has been the dr
john deloney show